back in 2016 apple did the unthinkable
they went up on stage and announced the
iphone 7
the first iphone to get rid of the
headphone jack which caused
a lot of people to get upset but apple
had
a solution and that was airpods
which they debuted alongside the iphone
7 and
in just a couple of years they went
absolutely viral
and the rest is history well now in 2021
we're finally expecting the regular
airpods to get its first major redesign
after five years
with the brand new airpods 3 that will
be coming out in just
one month alongside the iphone 13. and
if you don't believe me
i've got a bunch of leaks and rumors to
discuss that will basically confirm the
release of these new airpods so in this
video
i'm going to talk about the airpods 3
and all of the specs and features we're
expecting them to get
and then i'm going to compare them to
the previous airpods 2
the airpods pro and even the future
airpods pro 2
which are expected to come next year but
before i get into all that fun stuff
let's jump into the major leagues rumors
that we have so far about the airpods 3.
in february of 2020 it was reported that
apple was working on airpods pro lite
which basically looked like the pros but
lacked the noise cancellation features
which has now been confirmed to be air
pods 3.
and then in april digitime has basically
reported the same thing
but the new airpods 3 will simply have a
similar design to the pros
adding that they've been delayed into
2021 because of covid and once again in
june we heard the exact same
but this time coming from the reliable
analyst ming chi quo
in october of 2020 mark german from
bloomberg
confirmed airpods 3 are coming with the
pros design and without anc
but also adding that it'll have improved
battery life
and an upgraded wireless chip most
likely being the h2
moving on ming chukwu then claimed that
the airpods 3
will actually have a hybrid design
somewhere between the airpods too
and the airpods pro and then after that
we got our very first
look at a leaked pair of airpods 3 from
52 audio
where they look a lot like the airpod
pros but without the silicon tips
and by the way if you don't know who 52
audio is
that's the website which successfully
leaked the design of the airpods pro
before
they were released so they definitely
have a good track record
and according to the elec the airpods 3
may cost
1.99 which is actually the same price of
the current airpods 2 with their
wireless case
now here's a leak that's pretty insane
mr white shared a photo of an airpods
component
in black now this is something that i
honestly
can't imagine happening and personally
wouldn't really be excited for
because the pure white color of airpods
is extremely iconic
but you guys let me know what you think
after that 52 audio
started releasing more images of the new
air paws 3
and john prosser ended up saying that
those leaks are legitimate
then on march 10th gizmo china released
some brand new renders of the airpods 3
and they look basically identical to the
ones that 52 audio previously showed
we then got even more images of the
airpods 3 from 52 audio
which makes it convincing that these are
the exact air pods we will see at launch
and at the same time 52 audio added that
the price tag
will most likely be around 150 dollars
but i personally think that 200 is more
realistic
and then a few days later an investor's
note from ming chi quo
stated that mass manufacturing of
airpods 3
would begin in quarter 3 of 2021 which
starts
in july which means that airpods 3 are
being made
right now as we speak and very recently
on july 23rd
we got a new leak from deja times saying
that shipments of pcb
and sip modules or basically the chips
have started to take off which pretty
much suggests that we could be getting
air pods
this fall and then right after that we
got a tweet from dylan dkt
an apple analyst and ios developer
confirming that airpods 3 will release
this september
alongside the new iphone which would
line up perfectly to the leak from
digitimes
since then mark grimmon reported the
same thing agreeing with dylan dkt
so it looks like we're going to see
airpods at the same time that the next
iphone comes out
which makes a lot of sense now something
very interesting that has to do with
both airpods 3
and the next iphone is the new possible
support
for wireless lossless audio apple
released
lossless audio for apple music this past
june
for those with ios 14.6 and later
and to listen to it you need to either
use a wired connection
or use the built-in speakers in your
device now the weird part is that apple
is going
all in on lossless audio with them
announcing that they're going to try to
move their entire catalog
over to supporting lossless and the
reason it's weird is because of one
major issue right now you can't stream
lossless audio using wireless devices
like airpods airpods pro and even
airpods max
because current bluetooth connections
don't support lossless
however we've seen a lot of leaks about
the new iphone 13
coming with updated wi-fi 6e and
bluetooth 5.2
as well as mark rimmon saying that the
airpods 3 will have an upgraded wireless
chip
and those upgrades will make it possible
to add support for wireless lossless
audio
and we know that apple's been pushing
lossless like crazy lately
and there is no way that apple will
leave out their airpods from lossless
listening
apple makes a lot of money from airpods
sales
in 2020 airpods made more revenue than
nvidia
and amd combined and almost just as much
as netflix
and guess what apple makes even more
money from
services so it's a no-brainer move to
give airpods support for wireless
lossless
since it'll incentivize a lot of people
to get both new airpods
and an apple music subscription now
there are multiple ways that apple can
actually make this happen
so if you guys are curious let me know
and we might make a dedicated video
going into detail on exactly how apple
can pull this off
now with all that out of the way should
you upgrade to the aeropods 3
well that all depends on what you're
upgrading from
if you currently have airpods pro then
you should absolutely
not to get the airpods 3. as we know the
airpods 3 are going to adopt the pros
design
but they are not going to come with
active noise cancellation so there's
really no point in even
considering it because all you're doing
is downgrading to basically the same
device
but without anc apple is instead
targeting the airpods 3 to people who
still have the first
and second generation airpods from years
ago which is surprisingly
a lot of people even vadim one of the
hosts of this channel
still has the original airpods from
2016.
and for now he says he's totally fine
with them and there are actually many
people that actually prefer the regular
airpods to the airpods pro
because of the open-ear design compared
to an in-ear and i even know an
apple fanboy that loves to drop cash on
the coolest and most expensive products
and even he didn't upgrade to the pros
because he loves the fit of the regular
air paws
that much and as i said before the
airpods 3 are set to release at a price
of around 150 to 200
i'm honestly expecting the latter which
honestly is really good considering that
the airpods 2 with the wireless case
have an msrp of that much so if you have
air pods it's definitely worth upgrading
if you're considering it
now if you currently have airpods pro
and want to upgrade the only worthwhile
option
is to wait for the airpods pro 2. so
let's talk about what those are going to
be like
in october of 2020 mark grumman claimed
that the new airpods pro 2
will come with a brand new circular
design and an upgraded wireless chip
this definitely makes sense because if
the new airpods 3 are adopting the
airpod pro's current design
then they need to update the design of
the pros too so that they'll stand out
and there are already a lot of earbuds
out there like the amazon echo buds and
the galaxy buds that have a stainless
circular design
and they are fantastic having a flush
design makes earbuds much more
comfortable to lay down with
and you're easily able to do things like
change your shirt or a helmet
and not only that but they'd allow for
bigger batteries as well as far as the
release
ming chi kuo says not to expect the
airpods pro 2
until 2022 so it'll be a wait but there
have been a lot of whispers about a new
innovative experience that could have to
do with health tracking
and interestingly digitimes actually
reported that apple was gonna pack
ambient light sensors into a set of
airpods in the future
and apple track's take on their rumor
was that apple would use those sensors
to measure your heart rate and other
biometrics
as it would possibly be more accurate
than measuring on your wrist with an
apple watch
so that could be one of the added
exclusives to make the pro 2 stand out
even more
so based on those leaks if you currently
have the airpods pro
then you should sit with them for the
time being until the pro 2 get released
and if you have the gen 1 or gen 2 air
pods
then the upcoming redesign with the new
wireless chip is
definitely worth getting these new
airpods are going to be game changers
especially being the first wireless
apple products that could support
lossless audio
if you guys want to see a dedicated
video on how apple can pull that off
then click the subscribe button above
and hit the bell to be notified
so you don't miss out check out those
two videos over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next one